What Causes Hiccups
In medical terms, a hiccup can be called a
hiccough, a synchronous diaphragmatic flutter,
or singlutus.
Hiccups are classified into three categories:
normal, protracted or persistent, and intractable.
Protracted are those hiccups that last over
48 hours, but not more than one month.
Intractable hiccups continue for more than
one month.
If hiccups occur for less than 48 hours, they
are considered ‘normal’.
In regards to the function of hiccuping, it
was once thought that this act was just a
twitch of the diaphragm (the muscle that separates
the thorax from the abdominal cavity and is
the main muscle involved in breathing).
It has since been shown to be a much more
complex process.
It starts with a sudden, strong contraction
of all muscles involved in inspiration.
This is followed almost immediately by the
glottis, or vocal cords, closing shut.
This clamping of the chords is what causes
the infamous ‘hic’ sound.
The top of the mouth and back of the tongue
then move up, making an occasional associated
burp, as the diaphragm then contracts forcefully.
The heart will also tend to slow down during
this process.
This is thought to be caused by the stimulation
of the Vagus nerve, which slows a person’s
heart rate.
Precisely what causes this complex involuntary
reflex action is still up for debate, though
it is known that there are some common mediators
that trigger the reflexes.
Common causes are things like: eating excess
amounts of food; eating spicy foods; sudden
changes in stomach temperature, such as can
happen when eating something hot and washing
it down with an icy drink; consuming large
amounts of alcohol; exhaustion; or malnutrition.
Some medical conditions are also thought to
cause hiccups, usually hiccups of the persistent
or intractable variety.
The most common that also triggers normal
hiccups is stomach acid moving into the esophagus.
Neurological lesions involving the brain-stem,
metabolic disorders, irritation of the Phrenic
nerve (the one that goes to the diaphragm)
are also known to cause hiccups.
Other known medical causes of hiccups include:
hyperglycemia, anorexia, meningitis, encephalitis,
heart attack, stroke, multiple sclerosis,
blows resulting in brain damage, electrolyte
imbalance, kidney failure, certain types of
infections… the list goes on and on.
What exactly is going on in the body to trigger
hiccups from these varied causes is heavily
debated among researchers who study hiccups,
but the general consensus is that there must
be some built in system involved in triggering
hiccups, a “central pattern generator”.
Specifically, it is thought that there is
a central neuronal circuit that generates
hiccups, similar to the ones that allow us
to cough, breath, and walk.
Given the wide ranging conditions that can
cause hiccups and that the hiccups vary greatly
in duration based on a variety of factors,
this circuit must be conditional, only triggering
when certain conditions within the body are
met.
Hiccups themselves are thought to offer no
biological benefit to humans.
Further, the hiccup is commonly seen and heard
from fetuses on ultra sound, and occurs well
before any type of breathing movement in-utero.
It’s because of this that Dr. William A
Whitelaw, a professor at the University of
Calgary, has suggested the central circuit
involved is left over from a previous stage
of human evolution.
As evidence, he suggests looking to other
animals in nature that have hiccup-like actions
in their species.
For instance, he points to a tadpole that
breaths air through both lungs and gills.
While breathing air through the gills, a tadpole
will take in water and close its glottis at
the same time, allowing the water to be forced
out through the gills and not into the lungs.
This is a similar action as hiccups in humans.
While there is no known definitive cure for
hiccups, any online search will yield countless
suggestions and home remedies.
The University of Maryland’s Children’s
Hospital gives the following suggestions.
First, try breathing into a paper bag for
10 seconds.
This will raise the carbon dioxide levels
in your blood, which can help stop the hiccup.
Having someone scare or startle you, tickle
you, or taking a spoonful of sugar also has
been shown to occasionally cure hiccups.
Another method is to hold a very deep breath
as long as you can.
This will also cause blood carbon dioxide
levels to rise.
However, the deeper the breath you take, the
better it seems to work, so it may not just
be about raising carbon dioxide levels.
Bonus Facts:
• The world record for longest bout of hiccups
is held by Charles Osborne from Iowa.
He had the hiccups from 1922-1990.
That’s 68 straight years of hiccups.
Oddly, they randomly stopped about a year
before he died.
• The Old English word for hiccup “ælfsogoða”
derives from the fact that it was thought
hiccups were caused by elves.
• In 2007 a Florida girl (Jennifer Mee)
had a bout of uncontrollable hiccups at a
rate of about 50 times per minute that lasted
for approximately 5 weeks before stopping
on their own.
Later on she suffered periodic bouts, and
exhaustively sought an explanation from Doctors,
without success.
It was her lawyer, in 2010, who claimed that
they are a symptom of her other known medical
condition, Tourette’s syndrome.
Why her lawyer do you ask?
Because in October of 2010, Mee and accomplices
Laron Raiford and Lamont Newton were arrested
and charged with the 1st degree murder of
22 year old Shannon Griffin.
The three allegedly lured Griffin to a vacant
house where they robbed him and shot him several
times.
Mee’s lawyer claims her Tourette’s may
have played a role in the robbery.
As evidence of her diagnosis, he points to
her frequent hiccuping episodes.
• Another dramatic case of the hiccups occurred
in 2006 with a man named Christopher Sands
who lived in Lincolnshire, England.
Sands’ hiccups lasted around 3 years and
robbed him of his career as a musician and
vocalist.
His hiccups were so bad at times that he would
be unable to breathe properly and would occasionally
pass out from it.
He also had significant difficulty in sleeping.
Sands eventually received media attention
in 2009 and doctors in the United States investigated
and found he had a tumor in his brain stem
that was causing the hiccups.
After removing it, the hiccups went away.